[Musique]
étrangers
[Musique] [Musique
]
étrangers [Musique
[Musique]
appareils afin qu'ils puissent aller travailler le plus
tôt possible et utiliser cet
équipement aussi efficacement que possible aussi
efficacement que possible
étrangers
[Musique]
comment  savoir comment fournir aux mineurs
comment opérer par eux et c'était
très rapide et rapide mais je pense que nos
officiers nous sommes si intelligents pour
faire fonctionner ces détecteurs de métaux et
la pénétration du sol ou nos frères en
Ukraine et cela sera très utile pour
nettoyer notre  territoire des mines russes
et de l'oeil russe oeil de source
étrangère